well very good morning to you having
confirmed the latest easing of lockdown
measures in england the prime minister
could immediately be on a collision
course with many of his own mps and
government scientists conservative
backbenchers have criticized the idea of
covid passports saying they could lead
to a hellish
demi lockdown the later stages of boris
johnson's road map are also under
scrutiny this morning
with government scientists warning it
could cause hospital admissions to
rise to the levels seen in january our
political correspondent kate mccann
reports
what does normal mean in the wake of a
global pandemic
and what will people accept to get back
there again
these are the questions the government
is grappling with as restrictions are
eased across the uk
twice weekly testing and passports for
travel and leisure activities are both
set to be introduced
but not everyone supports the move i'm
sure that if they had given
freedom to people maybe they would have
been thinking differently but you're
enslaving them
you're telling them if you don't get
this you will not travel
i think i prefer testing rather than
having to just be like you have to have
a vaccine passport or something like
that that's not something i'd be happy
to do
like if they're making that mandatory i
wouldn't be happy with that personally
if the government wants me to take a
test twice a week to save lives then i
don't mind doing that
but whether they have the capability or
not
i don't know boris johnson was careful
to give little away on vaccine passports
he knows the issue is controversial
but on testing he said most people would
find it an acceptable trade-off for more
freedom
if things continue to go well i do think
that
for many people in many ways life will
begin to get back to you know at least
some semblance of normality but
you know we're still somewhere off there
we've got to be guided by the data
and we've got to make sure that we we
follow the the road map that's the way
to get that but his own mps are wary
mark harper the chair of the covert
recovery group
said trying to introduce these domestic
vaccine passports by the back door by
linking them to removing social
distancing rules just won't be
acceptable and scientist stephen reicher
has called for more honesty from policy
policymakers to help the public
understand why some measures will be
here for months to come
one of the most important things has
always been throughout this pandemic
to treat the public as a partner to
treat the public with respect
to be open with the information to be
clear about what the risks
are but then to explain what we can do
to move forward the reality is that
getting back to any kind of normal will
take months and force our political
leaders to confront some difficult
choices on the compromise between
freedom and control
but will the prime minister have the
support of his mps and the public
when he does kate mccann sky news
well just to bring you the latest
figures on the pandemic and 2762
new covert cases have been reported in
the last 24 hours with
26 more deaths across the uk
that takes a total number of people
who've now died to 126
862. the figures also show that 31.6
million first doses of a vaccine
have now been given that's 60 percent of
the adult population well let's talk to
vaccines minister
nadim zahawi good to see you as always
look can we start with
with what we heard from the prime
minister last night i mean obviously
there's very positive news
that he confirmed who had easing of
restrictions next week but
i mean he he was a bit slim on the
detail
of how we move forward i mean in
particular
things like the vaccine passports the
certification
we don't actually know how that's going
to be rolled out do we
good morning stephen i think it's
important to
just remember what the prime minister
said uh yesterday
that next monday you can go to a beer
garden and have
uh your beer there is no requirements
for
uh vaccine certification or uh
passports that are being referred to uh
in may you'll be able to go
inside uh the pub and enjoy your drink
and there is no
uh question of a vaccine certification
being asked for so i just want to sort
of allay some of those
uh fears now uh we need to unpack this a
little bit
for your viewers international travel a
number of countries have already
indicated that they're going to require
some form of certification
as they do now as we require a
pre-departure test certificate
um so it's important that we make sure
that operationally
that the protocols are you know designed
and work in a way that's
really advantageous to our citizens
which is why
the task force looking at this is
working through those protocols at the
same time as the nhs
is operationally making it viable so if
people do
need their certificate if and when it is
appropriate
uh for them to travel then they'll be
able to have that certification
uh available to them that's only right
now
use of certification domestically does
throw up a number of difficult
ethical questions which is why michael
gove has been consulting with businesses
with stakeholders
with colleagues in parliament so that we
listen to all sorts of views now
it would be completely remiss and
irresponsible of
government i'd be coming on your program
and you'd be saying to me you know
we've seen this work in in europe we've
seen it work in israel
why haven't we thought about this why
are we behind uh
other countries so it's only appropriate
and right
that we make sure that the technology
the operations are available
and ready to go for international travel
as and when that
is okay forgive me for jumping in
forgive me for jumping in the
international travel and we
will talk about travel a bit more in a
moment but i think a lot of people would
understand that the domestic issue
does cause some concern the prime
minister didn't rule out
uh passports for pubs last night you
seem to be saying this morning that that
is not going to be the case
but if you can say that category
categorically about
going inside to the pub from may onwards
then then why can't you say what's going
to be happening with things like
restaurants with things like
cinemas and and concert venues
so he he said that yesterday about
next monday in a pub garden uh in may
inside a pub he's made that very clear
but we're also
piloting a large large-scale uh
you know public whether it be sports
events like the
uh fa cup finals semi-final or other
events to look at how whether it's
testing
or vaccination or immunity
to the virus can help us open up
more of our economy it's only
responsible that we look at the
all the uh available data
and of course all the available routes
for us to get our lives back
as quickly as possible that is only what
you'd expect from us because if you know
if we're not doing this and we see it
working in other countries
the first thing you'd be doing is saying
why haven't you thought of this why
didn't you look at that
and that's only you know the right thing
to do and a responsible thing to do as a
government
is it going to be so but are you going
down the path of saying
you know if it is going to be required
it's going to be an enforceable
requirement or are you
going along the lines of it's going to
be up to some venues to decide what they
what they want to do well i think
as the prime minister said i'm going to
sort of plagiarize it you're jumping too
many fences at the same time
what we're saying is that for
international travel
if our citizens need to travel at the
right time when obviously
international travel returns we will
make sure that they're able to
demonstrate
their certification whether it be a
pre-departure test certificate
or a uh vaccination testification
domestically
the the the the step two which we're
coming
up to step three there will be
absolutely
no issue around uh pubs or restaurants
requiring any form of certification
but it's only responsible as we
see how this virus behaves as we see how
other countries are utilizing
technologies
to make sure that they keep the virus
under control then we should look at the
same thing it's only the right thing to
do
we're all working towards the same
outcome which is to
get our lives back get our economy
running whilst
this is this is all about clarity not
only for these businesses but for the
the consumers who who use them and we're
getting it to be fair we're getting
information from you some clarity that
we didn't get from the pm last night so
you're saying when
when things reopen like going inside to
a pub
going inside to a restaurant going
inside
to a cinema or for example because
obviously cinemas are looking to reopen
in may
you were saying are you that at this
point in time there is absolutely no
requirement that you're expecting
for a passport to be required of a
coveted passport to be required
to be fair that's exactly what the pm
clarified last night he said
that when you go to the pub garden on
monday
uh you'll be able to sip your pint
without requiring any form of
certification when you go inside the pub
on
may the 17th if we continue to obviously
make sure we look at the data there's
four weeks plus one remember
that we are going to make sure to keep
on top of this virus by make sure
making sure we keep looking at the data
you won't be needing
that uh uh covered vaccine certification
but we are looking at piloting large
scale events like the fa cup final
uh initially looking at testing using
testing as the technology
but also looking at other ways including
immunity and of course
vaccines as a way of making sure we
take as much of our lives back as
quickly as possible
if you continue to have your target as
being
working together to get our lives back
to get the economy up and running then
you won't get this wrong
okay um look um what is very important
it falls within your remit that i really
need to ask about is
is the the regulatory authority raising
some concerns
about astrazeneca the the oxford
astrazeneca jab
being given to the under 30s now we know
some research
has shown perhaps an elevated risk of a
blood clot
in younger people is it your
understanding that this is now being
looked at
so the mhra led by june rain have been
looking at this all the time they have
always made sure that they look at all
incidents with
all the vaccines that will be deployed
we're currently deploying at scale
pfizer and of course the
oxford seneca and they've been very
clear that the benefits
of the vaccine far outweigh any
uh of these rare incidents uh of risk
and if you get the call to take your
vaccine
but of course we will be guided by the
mhra by the joint committee on
vaccination
immunization as they continue to look at
these very
rare incidents uh and i think that's
only right and of course
just as a sort of reminder to your
viewers the mhra is independent of
government and they publish
through the yellow card system all
incidents as they did
last week as they're going to do again
so that's important
we've led the largest and probably one
of the most successful vaccination
programs
in the world the confidence that
vaccination program is because we have
such a
robust regulatory framework in the
united kingdom i think that's important
to remember as well and and june rain
last night
uh made it very clear that if you get
your uh invitation please come forward
between december stephen and the end of
february
the vaccination program has saved six
thousand
three hundred people over seventy from
dying so that puts it in perspective
oh absol absolutely it does but um but
we're not talking about
under unless it's under very specific
health reasons we're not talking about
calling the under 30s up to get their
vaccine
just yet and we know that different
vaccines have different strengths and
weaknesses within different
age groups i mean that that is
scientifically understood
so it is it prudent at this point to be
looking in detail now
at whether under 30s when it comes to be
their turn
need to be given a different vaccine
well as i said
the regulator uh continues as does the
european regulator
and the who to recommend that the
astrological opposite vaccine be given
to all uh ages over 18. they continue to
obviously
monitor and look very carefully at these
very rare cases
of blood clotting um again another
perspective on this we've done almost 20
million
uh vaccinations using the oxygen
asteroidal
vaccine and they make sure that they
they
look at each and every adverse incident
that
occurs at the moment they're very very
clear to say that if you get your
invite please come forward and take the
vaccine because it
protects you protects your family
protects your community we saw some data
from chris whitty
yesterday demonstrating the efficacy of
these vaccines but the
we will be led my my deployment team
will be led by what the
regulator will the scientists uh tell us
is the right thing to do we've got other
vaccines
um coming along including the modern
vaccine very shortly and then of course
the jansen jnj vaccine and more pfizer
and more oxidative zenica
so we we are in uh in a good place uh
because of what decision that matt
hancock and
uh and and boris johnson took very early
on last year
to make sure that we have the vaccines
available to us to be able to protect
the whole nation
and i'm confident by the end of july
look just
just to change uh track just to finish
with over this whole
david cameron green sill issue which is
causing concern about the transparency
of lobbying and what is go
you know what happens within the
corridors of power you were in the
policy unit
when lex green sill seemed to have this
rather strange rather unique access to
number 10
with his own business card and
government email address and everything
else
i mean did you think that was normal at
the time did he raise any concerns with
you
well i'd never met uh lex greensell um
during my work in the uh possibly or
since then
um the job he was doing unpaid
was to look at supply chains for the
then prime minister david cameron
all the uh usual approvals would have
been
gone through to be able to appoint him
as that
supply chain advisor to the prime
minister
and i think that's important we have got
you know the checks and balances in
place
uh that take place in terms of any
approvals of any advisor to any prime
minister
and i think that's important to remind
the your viewers of that
okay look minister we are sadly out of
time but good to talk to you this
morning thank you
very much indeed okay let's talk to
our political correspondent joe pike can
we talk about clarification from last
night's
news conference first and foremost
we sort of seem to get some
clarification
from the minister there but not quite so
75
clarification it would seem that that
that restaurants and perhaps cinemas and
things aren't going to need
certification what was interesting he
said he was repeating what the prime
minister said yesterday
he seemed to be going as you pointed out
quite a lot further than boris johnson
at yesterday's news conference boris
johnson saying
next week outdoors in a pub garden you
don't need a vaccine certificate well no
one ever suggests i think you
you would do mr zaharawi making it
pretty clear
that in restaurants and pubs inside in
may
there are no plans there'll be no
requirement no question
of vaccine certification needed i'm not
sure that is something
that we've heard clearly from a
government before
the other interesting news i think was
on concerns that the
mhra the vaccine regulator are
looking into the astrazeneca vaccine
whether there
are increased risks for under 30s the
government making it very clear
yesterday and today from the
vaccine minister that they think this is
safe and
they think people should get the vaccine
if it's offered we do know
that the mhra looking at it they've said
that no regulatory decision has been
made but for me as you say
the big news story seems to be that
there'll be no vaccine certification
in pubs and restaurants inside
in may okay joe thank you i saw the
karma for you
this morning dangerous and irresponsible
25 to 8 will talk to labour's shadow
health secretary jonathan ashworth
as he claims some parts of the country
will be left behind in the fight against
covert 19.
five past eight will talk to the head of
the israeli tourist office in london
could they be one of the first countries
to welcome back british travelers
and passport to the station screen at 8
20 we'll talk to the chief executive of
the uk cinema association
and the boss of one of the uk's biggest
regional theaters
would they consider checking vaccine
passports
at the door that was the minister there
it is perhaps unlikely
that they're going to need to though
absolute clarification
isn't there yet now sky news is the
first international broadcaster to reach
the center
of the mozambique town of palma which
was ransacked by extremist militants
linked to islamic state
our team saw bodies still lying in the
street and multiple
shops and homes as well as a hospital
that had been vandalized and satellite
people there told us the attackers were
well armed shooting
indiscriminately wielding machetes
and carrying out beheadings
well assaults from militants have risen
in mozambique's north in recent months
residents told sky news the attack on
the town of palmer on march the 24th was
well planned
many expats were trapped for three days
at the amaroola lodge hotel
a convoy of vehicles made a breakout
attempt but was ambushed with just a few
cars escaping dozens of people including
a brit
were killed a warning that this report
from our special correspondent alex
crawford
does contain some disturbing images
we're flown into palmer by military
helicopter it's the only way to the
center
after militant extremists rampage
through the town
in the remote northern cabo delgado
province
the town's now heavily fortified with
soldiers and special forces spread
throughout
it was the most audacious attack yet in
mozambique by militants linked to isis
and terrified residents are still only
just emerging after hiding in the bush
ever since they're all very hungry
they've survived on root vegetables and
rain water up till now
we're the first international
broadcasters to make it to the center
since the storming of palmer
we're with the governor of the province
who's also seeing the destruction for
the first time
those are people returning
the people there yeah they're returning
they feel it if they feel it's safe
the dead are still laying in the open in
the street
they haven't been able to retrieve them
up until now
and there are modest attempts to give
some respect to those who died in this
terrifying
and violent assault
we saw a body in what appeared to be
camouflage clothing
wearing an ammunition vest an outfit
favored by the terror group known as
al-shabab or isis mozambique
the attackers swept through palmer
setting fire to shops
homes and offices all the town's key
infrastructure was targeted including
the hospital
and the administrative offices and the
mobile phone network was destroyed
how can you guarantee it won't happen
again at this i can't say
this i can't say uh what i have to say
is that uh
we we are we are here with uh our troops
and
uh we we feel we feel okay
we saw the first residents to trickle
back into the town
after hiding for nearly two weeks
grabbing what they could
from the vandalized shops these are
desperate times for palmer's residence
the struggle to survive is not yet over
for those who managed to escape the
attackers
tensions are still incredibly high the
troops we were with
arrested three young men who they say
were acting suspiciously
that was a gunshot and we were
immediately hurried away and out of the
town
the military may have moved into palmer
but there are still multiple challenges
facing them
the attack has halted work on the 60
billion
liquefied natural gas project outside
palma on the afunji peninsula this was
meant to transform the fortunes of this
desperately poor region
now security's been stepped up the
project is vitally important for
mozambique's economy
but in the smaller fungi airport
terrified palmer families who've taken
refuge
there told us how they fled for their
lives so i started to run away to my
home
i went to pick up my family my wife and
the kids all of them then we went to the
bush
for the people there was followers in
the back so after that when we jumped
we jumped one river we found the people
with the gun they were shootings one and
one pips another and there's another
people also just
chipping at the people so we tried to
run away you saw this
i sold it with my my some of them with
my shirt
what are they doing they're killing
people how
they shoot people even they're following
or shooting us
then we run away
the governor went to try to reassure the
thousands of people who fled the
insurgents
and have now taken sanctuary in the
katunda resettlement village on the edge
of the lng site
village was built for those displaced by
the huge gas project
but the numbers have now swelled to
bursting
we're hungry we're hungry they keep
telling us and with all unaided flights
halted because of the militant attacks
these people have found
very little to eat or drink in nearly a
fortnight
they're all saying how hungry they are
and making us
stop this food look at them they're all
calling they're all saying food we want
[Applause]
food
[Music]
the governor promised they'd get help
and be able to return to palmer within
days
but they're getting more and more
desperate and more worryingly for
mozambique
is how it protects these people controls
this militant insurgency and stops it
from spreading
alex crawford sky news and cover delgado
mozambique
now police searching for the missing
london student richard okaragae say the
body of a man has been found in a pond
in essex well either bennett is in
epping forest in essex fours
this morning what are police saying
either
well the body body's yet to be
identified but this will nonetheless be
devastating news for richard's family
who when i spoke to them last week about
five days ago
i was still clinging to the hope that
their son was still alive
and over the weekend the police did
issue a direct appeal to richard to come
home to his loved ones in the hope that
he was somewhere
uh listening to them but then yesterday
they they made this discovery late
yesterday of
a body of a man uh in a pond uh an
epping forest a few hundred meters
uh into the forest in this direction we
can't actually broadcast from that
region so that's why we are
um here on the main road that cuts right
through the middle of epping forest
the police made this discovery on the
fourth day of searching this area
uh for any clues for richard okaragaya
the 19 year old i.t student at oxford
brooks university
the pond where they found this body is a
couple of miles or so from where
richard was last seen on cctv he was
seen getting out of a taxi
in the early hours of tuesday march 23rd
so full two weeks ago
heading out getting out of a taxi
outside a pub in laoton
and walking towards the forest he had
traveled here
from his home in west london around 20
miles away
earlier on that night after telling his
parents he had gone out to see a friend
it's still not clear what brought him to
lauten though his mother told me he'd
never been here before she had never
been here she didn't even know where it
was
and the family has no connection to the
area but she strongly believes that he
was speaking to someone online and came
here to meet them we know the police
were looking at his laptops and
computers
in the hope of finding some clues as to
what brought him here and clearly that's
going to be
a key part of the investigation going
forward as we wait for
identification of this body okay either
thank you
well this is sky news breakfast let's
see what the weather's going to do for
you today isabelle's over at the glass
box
good morning what have you got for us
today isabel
i've got a cold day again with a frost
first thing and
scattered winter showers temperatures
picking up a little bit though steve and
midweek before
they go down again into the weekend
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
there's actually sunshine streaming
through the windows here beautiful
morning there are snow showers around
still a bit of
sleet or snow in the showers across the
southwest this morning wales northern
ireland
and also across northern scotland
there's more showers to come today but
also quite a bit of sunshine as well
but it will feel cold wherever you are
we start off with a widespread frost
with some icy patches too
and there'll be a bit of wind blowing
particularly strong actually through the
day across the far northeast of scotland
especially the northern isles and that
surge of strong winds will come down
that east coast as we head through this
evening and tonight
some subtle changes tonight in that the
cloud melting away in land giving a
widespread frost again probably
colder than last night minus five minus
six celsius
and then during the day tomorrow yes
it's still chilly but the winds ease
there will be fewer showers around and
then as i hinted at temperatures pick up
a little bit
on wednesday night and thursday
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
isabel thank you still to come on sky
news breakfast we're going to talk to
labour's shadow health secretary
about his claim that some parts of the
country are going to be left behind in
the fight against kovid 19.
[Music]
[Music]
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm sky's chief
correspondent
the enormous explosion has just come
down
it's all snatched going in grabbing
people
you either live and recover or you die
okay so that's like a walk let's do it
we help you understand the world with us
over the past 24 hours the soldiers have
been attacked on a number of occasions
it's really sending a clear message that
venezuela is eager for change
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
they were convinced the united states
would become hooked well they were right
[Music]
we hear shotguns being fired
we've got our controversy withdrawn it's
so so hot
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now the vaccines minister has defended
the government's decision to pilot covid
passports following criticism that they
could lead to a two-tier britain
speaking to us this morning nadim zahabi
said they would not be required in pubs
or restaurants
but the government was exploring how
they might work for foreign travel
if our citizens need to travel at the
right time when obviously
international travel returns we will
make sure that they're able to
demonstrate their
certification whether it be a
pre-departure test certificate or a
vaccination testificate there will be
absolutely
no issue around pubs or restaurants
requiring any form of
certification but it's only responsible
as we see how this virus behaves as we
see
how other countries are utilizing
technologies
to make sure that they keep the virus
under control then we should look at the
same thing it's only the right thing to
do
the former boss of derek chauvin the
police officer accused of murdering
george floyd has told his trial
that mr chauvin's use of force was
unjustified
minneapolis police chief madaria
arredondo told the court
mr chauvin had absolutely violated
departmental policies
when he knelt on mr floyd's neck for
more than nine minutes
now sally lockwood has this report this
morning which does contain an
image of mr chauvin kneading on george
floyd's neck which
you may find distressing derek chauvin's
treatment of george floyd
did not follow minneapolis police policy
or
principles according to its chief
recalling in court the first time he saw
the video
that shocked the world a community
member
had contacted me and said
chief have you seen the video of your
officer choking and killing that
that man at 38th in chicago
a day after seeing the video of george
floyd's arrest
he fired derek chauvin and three other
officers
and very unusual testimony as a
prosecution witness
against his own colleague chief
arredondo said the forces number one
value
was sanctity of life it is my firm
belief that the
one singular incident we will be judged
forever on
will be our use of force derek chauvin's
restraint of george floyd was not
de-escalation he told the court then
came his damning verdict
of his former officers actions when mr
floyd was no longer
responsive and even motionless
to continue to apply
that level of force
to a person prone out
handcuffed behind their back um
that that in no way shape or form is
anything that
is by policy it's not part of our
training
and it is certainly not part of our
ethics or our values
george floyd's use of a counterfeit
twenty dollar bill to buy
cigarettes is not something that would
normally end in custody
according to the police chief the friend
who went to the store with him
is also due in court but expected to
plead the fifth
his right not to self-incriminate so how
much he's prepared to share
is another question sally lockwood sky
news minneapolis
we can see continuous coverage on sky
news streaming live
on our website and app on youtube and on
a special pop-up channel which you'll
find
on sky 524
now labour's warning that parts of the
country will be left
behind in the fight against coronavirus
research by the party suggests one in
five local authorities have seen a cut
in their public health budgets
during the pandemic well let's talk to
the shadow health secretary
jonathan ashwith good morning to you i
mean we look at the figures for
uh 2020 2021 into 21 22
there is actually something like a a 45
million pound
increase in the budgets isn't there
well that's when when you take into
account the budget
that has been allocated for a prep
which is an important um part of the
budget but that is that is ring fence
that has to be spent on prep which is
um which is welcome but but when you
take off that ring fence element
then you'll see that for a lot of areas
uh their public health budget
on a per capita basis on a one for one
you know per person basis is actually
being cut back and often these are
areas where their infection rates at the
moment are above average
so for example places like rochdale or
there may well be areas where there is
where
the infection rates are above average
but the budget is frozen
such as hartlepools kirklees uh
wakefield so we're saying to the
government if you that if you really
want to drive infection rates down
those local public health teams they
need the resources to do it
you shouldn't be cutting their budgets
or freezing their budgets you should be
giving them
more tools more resources so they can
get on and respond to covered
so so what impact are you thinking this
is
this is going to have in inter i mean
direct impact on people living in these
areas
well these are the public health teams
which are responsible for improving
public health in an area like harley
pool
or wakefield or rochdale so they need
the resources in order to invest in
their local communities to help them
promote
vaccination uptake to help them promote
um the social distancing rules that we
need to be following
if their budgets are being cut back on a
head-for-head basis
that then they're going to have they're
going to be less effective and i don't
think an area like hartlepool
should be left behind i don't think an
area like wakefield should be left
behind
we know it's got higher than average
infection rates because of covert at the
moment
they should be getting more help to
drive those infection rates down
they shouldn't be hindered in that
approach and that's my worry bank
by not substantially increasing their
budgets or even cutting them
on a head for head basis their response
to covid is hindered
i mean forgive me but you could
understand some people who may be
watching this
at home saying well look this is all
about messaging you talking about the
budgets for messaging surely people are
aware
of you know how to get hold of the
vaccine now
and and the the staffing and the
volunteering for those senses they're
aware of the
of the messaging on social distancing
is it really going to have that much of
an impact
well these public health teams are not
just not just responsible for messaging
they're responsible for population
health
across a locality so they're responsible
for services like drug and alcohol
addiction services they're responsible
for sexual health services they're
responsible for children's health and
health visiting and school nursing
and things like that these are really
really important health services
which are aimed at keeping people
healthy or allowing them
or improving the health outcomes uh of a
local area
and many of these areas do have
underlying health problems which
actually need
tackling and my worry is that by cutting
the budgets on a head of head basis
in wakefield and rochdale law not
increasing the budget substantially
in hartlepool uh of kirkleese which is
another area on the list
then you then what you are doing is you
are you are you're not
leveling up as the government has
promised you're actually
doing nothing about some of the
long-term health problems in these areas
and i don't think that's good enough i
think we should have a big strategy to
tackle health problems in these areas
um can i ask you about the the the covid
passport
situation talking to the vaccines
minister a short time ago
as no doubt you saw and he did offer
clarification that
you know vaccine passports are not going
to be needed
uh come may when we can go inside a pub
they're not going to be needed
when we go inside a restaurant but
keeping the door open to
modify that uh i guess as as
the you know as we move forward as as as
we look at the science
uh week in week out isn't that actually
a sensible strategy
i'm afraid ministers are really at sixes
and sevens on this
i mean last night boris johnson couldn't
explain
his own policy a few days ago boris
johnson was saying people can't meet
indoors if vaccinated
because the vaccine isn't 100 protective
you've now got the vaccine minister
saying it's not for
shops and pubs the document published
last night by michael gove
permits shops and pubs it allows them to
ask
for ask you whether you've got had a
vaccination
uh as a condition of entry the
government just
needs to clear this up because they're
creating confusion
i do think it's discriminatory to say to
somebody here in leicester that you
cannot go into next or h
m unless you produce your vaccination
status on an app unless you produce that
digital id
card i don't think that is fair now if
ministers are saying
that is not what the policy is then they
have to explain
why does the policy document they
produce last night
permit that scenario so there's a lot of
confusion
out there i just want ministers to be
honest and straight with us and tell us
exactly what their policy proposals are
but i mean it's
it's difficult i mean clarity is
difficult isn't it when
uh scientists on the sage group
also have said you know if if things
fully reopen
come june they're concerned about a
possible third wave
in this country i mean that then ties in
doesn't it to ministers saying
well this situation needs to be
constantly monitored we need to be able
to make
decisions moving forward based on what
the current uh
covert infection rates actually are oh
absolutely but there's ministers who've
introduced this idea of a digital
um vaccine id card and
they're the ones who've put this on the
table but when they've been asked
reasonable questions or at least when
boris johnson was asked entirely
reasonable questions at his press
conference last night
he wasn't able to defend it or offer any
convincing
answers now say the sage modeling as
government scientists
are modeling a potential third wave this
summer
with an extra 16 000 deaths i don't
think we should just glibly
accept that that modeling is a function
of the reality that there'll be
large proportions of the population who
are unvaccinated
and therefore the virus will still be
distributed across the country
what we need to do now is take further
measures
to ensure we avoid that scenario and the
most important measure we could take
is offering people proper decent sick
pay and support
to isolate themselves if they are a
contact or if they are ill with the
virus we still
are not doing that in a significant way
in this country it's the most monstrous
failing
of our response to this virus
forgive me for interrupting we're
running out of time but i mean is it
fair to say that you would be
if necessary happy to extend the
restrictions
into july and august we've always said
that these restrictions have to be
constantly kept under review
and in fairness that's the position of
the government
as well of course these things always
have to be kept under review you've got
to be guided by
the data you've got to be guided by
overall infection rate your over your
positivity rate
you do have to look at whether your nhs
capacity is set to be breached or not
but you've got to look at infections
across the board because we know that
this virus
a lot of people die from it but we also
know people who catch it
and don't die from it can suffer
debilitating long-term
fatigue conditions over a million people
now living with so-called
lung covid this isn't a horrific virus
so we always have to be
cautious and gradual in our response and
yes that does mean
keeping every stage of the road map
under review but as i say
that's not a sort of labor point that's
a that i agree with he would say this if
matt hancock was on your show
i'm sure he would say something similar
all politicians agree with on that point
okay jonathan ashworth got to leave it
there thanks for joining us this morning
thank you we'll sort of come for you the
nhs
unveils plans for a series of clinics to
help new
and also bereaved mothers with their
mental health
being in the water and being outside is
really good for your mental health and
well-being there's been quite a few
studies done in the last few years
um around that whole space and
i think surfing is great for children
particularly because it's fun
and it helps to
bring a sense of trust with the people
around you you know i think if you're
out in the waves
with someone else helping you it kind of
helps to give that sense of trust so
it's a kind of a combination of those
things that
brings the therapeutic benefits for
young people
both children are autistic and
school can be a really challenging
environment and there's kind of
associated mental health difficulties
with that so that kind of
lack of access to education or difficult
access to education and social isolation
is something that
it's been a part of special education
needs families for quite a long time
obviously lockdown made it a lot worse
but i think the
the referral was a massive um
a place of acceptance and um
challenge um and celebration
i think the the biggest thing of how the
um volunteers will
nurture support encourage and celebrate
every child as well as the obviously the
benefits of being outdoors
well i feel like i really enjoyed that i
never
i was never pressured into anything i
never had to do anything
because i was i always struggled with
quite
intense um physical activities
um and i never felt like
in this in the way project i never had
to do anything they would never make me
go into the water if i didn't feel like
it or if i felt uncomfortable with it
the role of the volunteers is really
important with the wave project because
each child gets their own what we call a
surf mentor so someone to work directly
with that child
one to one and build a bit of a
relationship with them
over time and that as i said earlier
that kind of whole idea of building
trust is
is really key to to it
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news's entertainment
podcast
but wherever you are welcome to the
safety rage what's monday podcast
for the ones who want to know more
welcome to the all that politics podcast
for the listeners from sky news
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free did you know that air pollution
isn't just bad for the environment it's
bad for our health too
it's a freezing cold start to the day
with a widespread frost and
some snow showers as well mainly up
across scotland northern ireland and
wales
there will be more developing inland
through the day as well so a little bit
of sleet or snow or hail possible but
they
will be well scattered many places still
dry inland but obviously
very cold and particularly windy for the
northeast and running down the eastern
coast of the country as well but with
this air mass
the air pollution remains low generally
speaking although there will be some
moderate levels
of air pollution across the northern
isles and the north coast of scotland
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
now there are plans by the nhs in
england for 26
mental health support hubs for new
expectant
or indeed bereaved mothers okay well
let's talk to nhs england's national
mental health director claire murdoch
morning to you
why is this a necessary move claire i
mean
we'll talk about the bereaved side in a
moment but for new and expectant mothers
why is this a necessary thing
yes good morning to you well mental
health is a top priority for us in the
nhs
generally we're investing 2.3 billion
pounds in it by 2023 and we hope to see
two million more people
a year every year by then so mental
health is
important and a top priority of the
people that we hope to see
we intend to provide new and
evidence-based treatment to some 66 000
women uh pregnant and new mothers
and we know that one in four
either expectant or new moms in the
first two years after birth
can experience mental health problems
now the clinics that we're launching
today the maternal mental health hubs
have a particular focus we've been
rolling out specialist perinatal
services we call them
across the country these last three
years and we're now seeing
30 000 women a year more than we did but
these hubs have a very particular focus
for women who've experienced birth
trauma
miscarriage for example or multiple
miscarriage
other trauma and indeed sadly the loss
of infants
forgive me for jumping in but how how
then are these people going to be
sort of contacted and brought on board
for this service is it going to be
relying on them
to ask for help well of course
every pregnant woman will have a
midwife will be engaged in maternity
services
and these hubs will be very much
integrated
into the entire network of maternity
services across the country
obviously in the first year we're
developing 26 of these hubs across the
country so
women can be referred by their midwives
or health visitors
or indeed their gps and one of our key
messages in the nhs is
we are here for women intending to get
pregnant or
during pregnancy or after pregnancy if
they are struggling with their mental
health please
do come forward um we know that new moms
especially can feel very concerned about
either the stigma
or being seen as not coping somehow
please speak to your gp or midwife
your health visitor family or friends
or in fact the mental health mental
health services nationally
do have 24 7 crisis lines that we've set
up
during the past year so i was going to
say i mean obviously there's
for people who've suffered a lot of
miscarriages or for bereaved mothers
it's a slightly different scenario but
for those people who are suffering
trauma after a healthy live
birth there can be this feeling can't
they but they are
they are failing at a time that is meant
to be the happiest of their lives
yes look as a nurse and a mother myself
i know we all know that um having a new
baby
can be a really happy and special time
for families
but all too many women and their
partners will know
that a severe birth trauma can stay
with that woman for a very long time
um and as she brings up her new baby she
can experience flashbacks in the most
extreme cases
she can suffer from post-traumatic
stress disorder and
we know much more about this now and
that's why the nhs is stepping up
and hoping to see with these new 26 new
hubs across the country
we think we'll reach about 6 000 women
who have got very particular kinds of
trauma and
these hubs and the staff working in them
will be highly specialist
and not only will they provide treatment
and please come forward your well-being
is absolutely at the heart of this these
plans
um but we'll also be providing training
to
uh maternity services midwives gps
health visitors
who will who are already very expert but
these services that we're launching
today will
give highly specialized evidence-based
treatment
very effective we are out of time i'm
afraid but really good to talk to you
thank you
and it's so important to forget that
that stigma is going now and if you do
need help
do reach out and get it it's really
important
let's see if the weather is going to be
decent today are we seeing a little bit
of a peak in temperatures isabelle today
yeah they do go up a little bit the next
couple of days but they go
down again at the weekend but let's take
a look at today
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
today though in more detail we start off
with a widespread frost icy patches too
where we've got
wintry showers rain sleet and snow
showers continuing to pepper coastal
areas and there'll be one or two
developing inlands through the day as
well some snow or hail possible
it's definitely cold though temperatures
for most only around five
six celsius really quite pitiful but the
cloud melts away
and tonight there'll be a widespread
frost once again
perhaps as low as minus four to minus
six celsius
hopefully tomorrow though fewer showers
but it stays cold
for the time being
the weather sponsored by qatar airways